now let's return now to Jeff Court the
scene of the church shooting in Texas
he's in southern Springs that's about 30
miles southeast of San Antonio he has
more on the church shooting Jeff good
morning hi again Gil the tragedy here in
Sutherland Springs is the latest in a
series of large-scale acts of gun
violence the country has experienced
mass shootings in more than 10
communities this year nearly a hundred
people were shot and killed in attacks
on so-called soft targets those are
relatively unprotected sites like
businesses concerts and houses of
worship now a church has been targeted
again
mark Strassmann is here with the debate
over how to secure unprotected places
market morning morning Jeff Foote
churches the sanctuary and by definition
a sanctuary is a place of safety until
it's not here in Texas and across the
country there are now calls to post
armed guards at churches to prevent acts
of violence like this but some critics
say that strategy could backfire I think
it's incumbent on every organization
where people gather to discuss proper
security Bishop Darnell Dixon believes
the best way to protect his church in
Raleigh North Carolina is with armed
defenders if I call people together it
is incumbent upon me to make sure they
are safe Dixon is voicing his concerns
following Sunday's massacre in
Sutherland Springs Texas and a long list
of religious sanctuaries hit by gun
violence in 2012 a gunman murdered six
people praying at a Sikh temple in Oak
Creek Wisconsin three years later
nine parishioners were shot and killed
at mother Emanuel AME Church in
Charleston South Carolina and in
September a shooter killed one woman and
wounded seven other people at a church
in Nashville Tennessee in an effort to
make it easier for places of worship to
provide volunteers security services
Texas passed a law in June waiving state
requirements on training licensing and
background checks so far I was just
where it can go drastically wrong Chuck
Chadwick has trained and
certified more than 350 personal
protection officers at churches across
Texas he says looser restrictions are
not the answer
especially in these rural areas you need
somebody who is already there that has
been trained in some kind of tactical
way in order to have a chance at a
church shooting in Colorado Springs in
2007 a member of the church's volunteer
security team shot the gunman and in
Mississippi last year the state passed a
law allowing churches to post armed
security hard to believe that has come
to this mark thank you very much